[MUSIC]
So I was an Army intel officer,
spent most of my time out of
Fort Benning and I chose Stanford for
a couple reasons.
One, I was a West coaster,
I grew up in Oregon originally.
And I'm married, and so we thought long
term we wanted to be on the West coast.
And so that kind of dropped out some of
the East coast schools from what we were
really seriously considering,
sort of my geographical preference.
And then the two winners outside that for
me were kind of entrepreneurial focused,
and I don't just mean
Tech VC entrepreneurship.
When I think about entrepreneurship,
I think about it in a wide sense of,
I get the sense from Stanford
that we have one of the more,
people go from the Stanford MBA
into a wider degree
of things post MBA than from
other schools that I looked at.
So I didn't know exactly
what I wanted to do, so
I got excited about having a school
that would allow me to look at,
seriously look at anything from
government work to non-profits to
entrepreneurship of all kinds to
standard consulting, finance, etc.
And then culture fit,
I'm kind of a West coast casual guy,
I didn't want to go to a business
school that wanted me to wear a tie or
a suit, and
I liked the kind of first name basis.
Everyone's here to help each other,
not competing to rank, things like that,
that was kind of my style and
I thought the school matched that well.
>> So my name is Nico,
I was in the Navy., a submarine officer,
and I chose Stanford for
several reasons as well.
The last five years I was in New England,
never lived on the West coast, so
I definitely I was interested
in a new change of pace.
I also felt that what
was unique to Stanford is that I
would be outside my comfort zone.
And that I think everything
from the classroom setting
to the clubs to events like small group
dinners, there are opportunities,
literally throughout the day where you
can really get to know your classroom or
your classmates,
especially with the class size about 417.
You really do get to know
all your classmates, so
that's something that
really resonated within me.
And I was also, like Sawyer said,
very interested in the entrepreneurial
aspect and I feel that Stanford lives and
breathes the entrepreneurial spirit.
So there anything you can think of,
I truly believe you can
kind of make a reality here.
>> I'm Katherine, I was a captain in
the Marine Corp, a supply officer,
spent most of my time in Okinawa,
and I chose Stanford kind of for
similar reasons to what Nico said, I
wanted to get outside of my comfort zone.
I was born and raised on the East coast,
went to undergraduate in Boston and
never lived on the West coast before,
so wanted to kind of try something new,
a new culture.
Also, the entrepreneurship aspect was
really outside of my comfort zone as well.
There's a lot of people here that
are willing to take risk on a big idea
that they have, and I thought it was just
a really exciting atmosphere to be around.
And finally, and this was a sense that
I kind of had before I got to Stanford,
but it's really been hammered
home since being here is,
it really truly is
a collaborative culture as well.
People are genuinely rooting for each
other to succeed and really eager to help
out their classmates in whatever way
they can in achieving their goals.
So, I'm really glad that I came here and
I think I made the right choice for me.
>> My name is Ryan Bolles,
I was an F18 pilot in the Marine Corps.
And for me I think the GSB,
when I looked at it, a lot
of schools had very unique opportunities
that I wouldn't be able to find elsewhere.
And one thing that kind of stood
out is that, the program and
the institution really focused
on developing students beyond
the classroom and trying to help
you fully develop as a person.
And one thing that stood out to me was a
quote that when people graduate from here,
when they walk across the stage they feel
just more comfortable in their own skin.
Which is a very qualitative type measure,
but I thought was very important and
a crucial element to be able
to make this transition and
enter into a completely new industry and
completely new workplace.
>> One question that came up earlier for
the group and
one that I want to pose here is,
can you talk a little bit about what
the transition was like from being
in service to being a student?
>> Yeah, so, I'm starting but I'm also
probably a little different than most
people on this call, which is,
I actually separated from the Army, and
then had about 18 months of work in the
civilian world before I came to the GSB.
So that is possible for
those who are kind of feel like veterans,
being a veteran or being on active duty or
are in the reserves now was one
career ago or a couple years ago.
There are those of us who do that, I spent
after doing my time in the Army, I spent
a little time kind of in the startup and
early investing world in Seattle, and
then applied from there down,
and came down to the GSB.
So that's a non-traditional track, but
you can separate and then apply and
still kind of leverage what you learned
and your experience as a veteran within
the application and
then once you're at school.
>> Cool, anybody else on the transition?
>> I could speak on
the other end of Sawyer.
I separated, went on terminal in July and
then I came to Stanford in September.
So it was a fairly quick turnaround for
me, but I would say,
just based off the programming that's
available to all incoming MBA ones,
that It was a very good, structured format
of getting into the groove of things,
getting to know your classmates.
And so it really wasn't a time demand or
a time sink for
me to kind of transition,
other than moving out here.
So, I thought that Stanford set it up
pretty well for not just military, but for
everyone to come together and kind of
get to know each other and get started.
>> Cool, so I'm actually going to use
this as a transition to our Q&A box.
So for our attendees,
this is the time to start asking some
questions about the experience,
again, from the experts.
Just wanted to let people know
about my appreciation for
the the Vets Club and
everybody on this panel.
Today's event is really supported
by the energy of our Vets Club, and
this came about because of their advocacy
and support for future veterans,
so, much respect, so much appreciation
to them for helping launch this event.
So the question that tailors
off of your response, Nico, is,
how does the civilian-military dynamic
on campus, how does that shape up?
So you mentioned a little bit
about that transition and
Stanford kind of easing that a little bit,
but how does that play out on the ground?
Do people tend to stick with
people from similar industries or
is there like a bridge and
what does that look like?
Yes, and I saw one of the examples was
leadership labs, for those that are not
familiar leadership Labs is a core course
that you take in your first quarter here.
And that's where you get to be
in an experimental setting,
get to go through roleplay scenarios.
And at least for me I had experience
that it really resonated with me
because the scenarios that played
out I felt like I had seen some
aspects previously due to
my military experience.
And for those reasons I felt
that it was a huge benefit to my
team being able to share
those experiences with them.
I will say that compared to
maybe what other schools are,
the veterans club is not that large, so
it's kind of in that sense it
is what you can make of it.
So there there are going to be people
that may not necessarily know that much
about the military.
So the onus is a little bit on you
to kind of help them understand and
it's an extremely great conversation
starter talking about your experiences
because everyone here is very receptive
and very curious to learn more about you.
So it's a very good opportunity to
kind of share those experiences and
then the there are instances like in
leadership labs where you can really
show the leadership experiences
that you gained in military.
>> I would agree with what Nico said,
everyone here is really open to learning
about their classmate's
different experiences.
And the vets club itself isn't
really an insular, isolated club and
the community it's one that is
constantly reaching out to our peers and
our classmates to share experiences,
see what questions that they have.
The culture on campus is so
collaborative that you really naturally
bridge that gap and
get to know each other,
they'll get to know you as people to not
just as the veteran in the class, but.
Like you're a more three dimensional
human being than just that, so
they'll really want to know about
your experiences and military but
also just want to get to know
you as a person as well.
>> All right, so,
speaking about experiences,
can you tell us a little bit
about something unexpected
that you experienced either during the
admissions process or while at the GSB?
>> I don't mean to be like
dismissive of this, but
I think the most surprising
thing was getting accepted.
And I say that because I think
there are a lot of people that
probably don't apply to the school
because the acceptance rate is low.
Anecdotally, like I am probably below
the average for most of the numbers that
you see on the website, but
I'm still sitting in this program and
I think that's because Stanford
looks a lot at the entire person.
And I think the essays are,
something that you can use to
stand out amongst your peer group.
And I'd say like if you're
interested in the school and
you're interested in this program,
the cost is literally just the time it
takes for you to fill out the application.
And I think the application to this
program is very unique, in that
there's really no opportunity cost because
it's a massive reflection exercise.
And I think that's just like a value add
and a benefit to anybody that's that's
applying to these programs to like really
think about why they want to do it.
What they hope to get out of it,
which I would submit as an and
really important thing to know
when you walk onto campus and
in the fall to any program
that you you enter.
Because things happen very quickly and if
you have even just general guidelines for
where you're looking to move
will be very beneficial.
And I think you'll extract more value
out of the program than if you try and
go, in a million different
directions at once.
>> Cool, so you you mentioned a little bit
about the acceptance on that admission
process, there is a question here
that's addressed towards Sawyer,
and I think, you indicated that you're
going to going to answer it live.
So I think this could be
a great chance too, and
open it up to also other panelists,
if you have thoughts on this.
So, Sawyer earlier mentioned that he
had not decided exactly what he was
going to do after his getting his
MBA like, how did you approach that?
And how did you share that?
Especially knowing that some other
folks are in the same boat now that
you were in then?
>> Yeah, actually going back to answer
one of the surprising things for me,
the first thing that came to mind is
when I got the call that I was admitted,
the admissions officer who called me,
said that she was excited for
my wife and I to be here and
named my wife by name.
And I thought like, I don't know if
I put my wife's name in any part of
the application and apart I is how much
research do they do, or something?
But on the other hand, it really felt
like they had looked at my application,
and got excited about me as a person and
the family I was bringing,
and so
that to me was like kind of strong signal.
Okay, it wasn't just like, I checked the G
matte box checked like recommendation box
like they knew who they were getting,
and they were excited, so
that was pretty compelling for me.
On the application, yeah,
I didn't know what I wanted to do,
I didn't know what I wanted
to do all last year either.
So and a lot of people come in
with that perspective I think,
whether they admit it or not.
As Ryan said, it's a lot of self
reflection and figuring out what's next.
[COUGH] So my recommendation is how
I articulated it in the essays and
the application was,
here are the things I care most about,
and these are parts of my past
that have made that clear to me.
And I want to spend more time Solving
this general area of problems,
I want to invest in small communities,
I want to develop leaders, I want to help
those who come from rural areas like I do,
I don't know how to do that yet.
But I know that because of these
experiences, business is a way for
me to do that.
And I want to spend two years at
the MBA program, getting the skills and
reflecting on how to do that better.
And that was kind of how I wrote it, and I
was concerned that it was a little vague,
I wasn't saying,
I want to be a consultant in two years and
then do this, I wasn't being specific,
but it was true.
I hope that the truth of I don't
know exactly what this looks like,
but I know what I care most about, and
I know Stanfield will help me to be able
to get there, I think that came through.
So I'd encourage people not to
try to write something they
think the ad comm wants to hear,
I think that does not hold the power of
being true even if it's a little unsure.
>> Yes, I second that just speak
to what's meaningful for you,
and this also kind of addresses one of
the questions from earlier today is how
much exploration happens
during business school.
So kind of nice to see how this has
gone a little full circle here, okay.
So, there is a question here
about the experience, so
we're going to shift gears
just a little bit here, so
Katherine and Nico,
this is a question from Danny.
In your intros you mentioned coming
to the GSB to push your comfort zone,
and to push yourself out
of your comfort zone.
Can you tell us maybe is
there like an anecdote or
story that encapsulates like
a moment where that's happened?
I think one of the things that they do
at Stanford is consistently try and
set up spaces where people can
make themselves vulnerable.
And really share stories about their
past or things that make them insecure.
That was a very unfamiliar thing to me,
and
I think still is kind of something
that makes me uncomfortable.
Making myself so vulnerable and open to
people that, some people I might know,
some people I might might
not even know that well yet.
One of the things that they do every week
at Stanford is had something called Talk,
where people can just talk for 45 minutes
about a story that's meaningful to them.
And so far, I haven't done one yet,
but I plan on doing one next year.
And they've all been
really powerful stories,
the stories that the classmates
have shared so far.
And I'm excited for the chance
to maybe share my story as well.
>> Yes, I would second
everything that Catherine said.
There are things that are sprinkled
throughout one's day at Stanford that can
really give you the opportunity to
come outside your comfort zone.
I distinctly remember the very
first class of managing groups and
teams is when the teacher told us,
or the professor told us,
all right, introduce yourself to
the person sitting next to you.
And don't say hi, don't say how are you?
But delve right into the question about
tell me the story behind your name.
And I was just taken back a little bit,
because I'm thinking when I meet people,
or are introduced, or get to know someone,
maybe that's not a conversation
I comes up at all.
But there are instances like
one day that I experienced,
where they kind of have this way of
being able to kind of deep quickly and
establish that that
trust in that community.
And like Catherine said,
there's the opportunity where you
have classmates that give a talk for
40 minutes.
And some of them,
they're really deep and personal.
And these are kind of opportunities
that you're thinking to yourself,
in another setting,
I don't know if I would have been able
to learn that much about somebody else.
And so I'm grateful that there's
these opportunities to kind of step
outside the comfort zone at Stanford.
>> Cool, so-
>> Can I just?
I think another thing that helps you is,
like a lot of MBA programs, there's this
policy of grade nondisclosure as well.
So if you're looking to get out of your
comfort zone in a more academic practical
sense, it's pretty low risk to take
courses that really challenge you a lot.
Because even if it is pushing kind of
yourself way past what you've ever done
before, and you don't get the best
grade or the grade you were hoping for,
it doesn't really matter.
The course program is designed for
you to be able to try those new things and
really push yourself.
>> Great, and so question here, we
talked a little bit about the transition
the application process, transition to the
GSB, a little bit about the experience.
And now already starting
to think of the next steps.
Can you guys talk a little bit
about the job hunt process?
And the recruiting process,
what's that like?
Especially if you happen to be considered,
and
you're not sure what you want to do
just yet, what does that look like?
>> Yeah, I can stat us off here.
So there's a specific question here
from Ryan about recruiting process,
how quickly does it start
upon arrival at the GSB?
And how do you engage with
that if you still are unsure?
So for me, I was unsure.
And I actually started
kind of working backwards,
I thought about things
I didn't want to do.
And as I went to some of
the recruiting events and
things that happened, I became clear I
didn't really want to do consulting,
I didn't want to do some of
the traditional finance stuff.
Some of the big tech companies
weren't appealing to me, so
I just kind of started limiting.
I went from what's all possible to
then marking things off the list.
And I didn't have an internship
fully locked in till probably
spring quarter, and that was fine.
There's a lot of pressure here in the fall
if you're doing traditional recruiting and
maybe every MBA to get
that locked in early.
But many, many,
many people don't have internships or
certainly real clarity about their
jobs until a few months before summer.
And I guess one thing that's a little bit
specific to the GSB is there's an academic
adjustment period in the fall.
Which basically prevents
recruiters from harassing you or
having events or
anything til Thanksgiving, I think, Will?
It's eight weeks or six weeks.
So all of the first years
are basically on lock down.
And I found actually that,
that was great for the first month or so.
because it allowed me still be here and
meet people and focus on school, and
the move, and things like that.
But then I actually started kind of
getting antsy, I want to go explore now.
But I thought it was a nice time,
because then I couldn't expect myself
to also be doing the job hunting yet.
Because technically it was against school
policy, and I wasn't getting emails or
getting recruiter things or having events
every night I feel like I should be at,
it was all kind of quiet.
>> I can maybe add some points as well.
Definitely second the academic adjustment
period, that's where I mentioned,
I found that to be pretty helpful to
allow me to focus on one area at a time.
[LAUGH] I think in the veteran
community this might echo or
was a bit of a phased approach for me.
And academic adjustment period was kind of
like a line where I was shifting my focus
from academics until that ended.
And then trying to blend in some
recruitment along with academics.
One thing that I did before coming
to school was explore some of,
on the more traditional side,
some companies and
firms will have things that you
can either attend over the summer.
So if you have the opportunity to
take terminal leave or vacation or
stop working with a little bit of
space before you start school,
I think that was very helpful to
do formal and informal searching.
So I did some research on the Internet,
I spoke with people in industries.
And kind of started to hone the questions
that I wanted to ask people so
I could really listen to their answers and
see what resonated with me and
what I wanted to focus on.
I ended up focusing on consulting.
I went through a fairly large cycle,
including
an internship at Goldman that kind
of directed me away from some
other industries as well as
looking at stuff in tech.
And I thought that
the recruitment process,
when that probably more traditional
process started, it is pretty fast.
So if you do think that that's what you
want to go down, or your research and
reflection over the summer
starts putting you on that path.
It's good to do a little bit of
the pre-work before that kicks off,
because when academic adjustment period
ends, you're kind of in a massive sprint.
From I think it was like
October through January,
until final round
interviews were complete.
Yeah, how did folks facilitate learning
about job opportunities or pivots?
Did you use the Career Management Center?
Did you network through events on campus,
through classmates or alumni?
What were some of the different ways
that you've engaged with the recruiting
process?
>> We attended a lot of events
that were hosted on campus.
But I also talked a lot to my classmates
because your classmates are going to
have worked in all of these industries
that you're looking at, most likely.
Including, you'll probably have classmates
that have founded their own companies in
the past, and
have experienced entrepreneurship as well.
So really almost anything that
you might be interested in,
you can probably find a peer that has done
something like that and would be more than
happy to sit down over coffee, or
take a walk and have a chat about it.
>> I did a lot of some events,
a lot of brown bag lunches where companies
will come and talk about themselves or
their industry.
And usually there were some business
cards because they want an intern or two.
And they'll literally be every lunch,
everyday of the week at lunch,
there'll be multiple brown bag lunches.
And usually you get free food and
you get to listen to the company.
If you're interested, shake their
hands afterwards and talk to them,
follow up email.
So I did a lot of that.
I also found I did a lot,
I held myself accountable to a couple
alumni reach outs per week, I think for
the first two quarters I was here.
And I found that particularly effective,
especially in the veteran community,
because it's a really small community.
So there is one veteran
who graduated from here,
probably ten years ago, I've never met.
He was in the navy, I was in the army.
And he has no connection to me other than
he went to the GSB ten years ago and now
works as an investor in Texas for a big
Silicon Valley entrepreneur kind of guy.
And not only did he take my first call,
but then he suggested a time to follow up
next week, we had about a 45-minute call,
and I was out of questions.
I didn't even know what's talking about
anymore, but he was just so happy to chat.
And that kind of daisy chains onto
you're interested in this, hear me,
you got to talk to this guy or
this guy on.
And so I found the veterans alums to be
super helpful, small but really impactful.
>> Cool, and we're getting
closer this part of the section.
So if we can close out,
I have one question that actually
encapsulates a couple of different things
folks have been asking in the Q&A box.
If you could share something like a piece
of advice, either with applicant you or
like MBA one year you when you were just
starting, what would that advice be?
>> Yeah, for MBA one me, I would say
that if you haven't heard already,
there is this notion of the FOMO,
or fear of missing out.
There are going to be a lot
of events going on on campus.
You got your classwork, you got
these career events, you have clubs.
And then you have just the natural
tendency of classmates just wanting to
hang out, grab a drink, or
go for a walk, or whatnot.
And it can very easily
overwhelm you very quickly.
And the thing is, just treat it like
you've treated anything else in the past.
It's something that,
it's okay to say no to certain events,
it's okay to take certain time.
There's not this notion that everyone's
doing something at any given time.
This is your journey, so make sure you
take time to do what you want to do.
And if you need some time off
to make sure you do that,
make this experience how you
want this experience to be.
[MUSIC]